apple tv's foundation is an epic sci-fi
story spanning several centuries based
off the 1951 trilogy by isaac asimov the
premise is somewhat simple a brilliant
mathematician by the name of harry
selden has created a mathematical
equation that can predict the future and
this future does not look good according
to harry if humanity fails to make
drastic changes it will endure 30 000
years of war and destruction this
doesn't sit well with the current ruler
of the empire who believes harry's
claims to be treasonous and an affront
to his power this is brother day also
known as the emperor he's a member of
what is known as the genetic dynasty a
long line of clones that have held onto
power for over 400 years when one of
them gets old they pass power on to a
younger copy so at any one time there
are at least three emperors of varying
ages brother dawn brother day and
brother dusk absolute power is
consolidated through brother day they're
based off of the first emperor known as
cleon the first and this ensures the
empire is ruled by a constant and
consistent hand but this also has its
downsides at the end of episode 1 a
group of insurgents blow up the
starbridge a massive tower that
transports people from space to the
planet trant or surface planet trantor
is the empire's home planet this attack
causes a hundred million deaths and only
emboldens the emperor to take action
against harry who sees the attack as the
first of many catastrophes to befall
humanity in the upcoming age of darkness
but brother day is smart instead of
executing harry he decides to exile him
to a planet on the outer reaches known
as terminus his intention is to let him
continue his work and should harry's
predictions come true use it to further
increase his power what greater weapon
for an emperor than a formula that can
predict the future this mathematical
equation is part of what is called
psycho-history psycho-history is a
predictive model designed to forecast
the behavior
of very large populations so harry is
tasked with starting a colony on
terminus and establishing what is known
as the foundation the thinking here is
that when civilization crumbles as he
has predicted humanity will need
something to build on rather than start
from nothing they'll have a foundation a
giant encyclopedia of sorts containing
all of humanity's greatest achievements
and technologies he says that with a
successful foundation this age of
darkness can be reduced from 30 000
years to a thousand for the emperor
exiling harry is a win-win if it turns
out harry's predictions are rubbish he's
already exiled if it turns out they're
true he can use it to further bolster
his own power in episode two while on
route to terminus harry selden is killed
by his adopted son reish but unbeknownst
to the crew this is all an elaborate
plan for something far greater a plan
that will see the overthrow of the
empire and the end of its tyrannical
rule this leads us to the events of the
season's final episode which starts with
harry's casket being shot out into space
prior to his death a death orchestrated
by harry himself he took a pill
containing millions of self-replicating
molecular machines these machines broke
his body down and became one with his
casket creating what is known as the
vault the vault landed on terminus
before the settlement arrived and no one
could really examine it because of a
self-defense feature known as the null
field it's an invisible force which when
one would get close to it would make
them pass out there was one person
however who was impervious to this field
that's salvor hardin the warden of
terminus but we'll get to her in a bit
as we begin the final episode two rival
factions have arrived on terminus
bringing their centuries-long hatred of
one another to the planet these are the
anakrians and thesmans and it looks as
though all-out war is imminent if it
weren't for the arrival of harry selden
emerging from the vault it's not the
real harry selden more so a
manifestation of his consciousness and
this was all part of his plan to create
a new civilization not ruled by one
voice like the empire but of many he
goes on to say but the foundation was
never about
curating knowledge
it was about curating people but how
does he hope to manage this with these
two factions who absolutely hate each
other throughout the course of the
season the show has stressed the
importance of history how whoever writes
it can turn a villain into a hero and a
liar into a truth-teller this is what
happened centuries ago with cleon ii the
first of the genetic dynasty clones he
had these two upstart kingdoms the
anacrians and thesmans who were only
getting more powerful by joining their
two kingdoms through marriage so he
orchestrated a murder involving the
royals to make it look like one of the
kingdoms backstabbed the other and voila
he rewrote history in his favor why
fight two upstart kingdoms when you can
exploit their racial animus
and have them fight each other harry
believes that if they all join together
they can bring about the downfall of the
empire and create a new civilization
that will withstand the dark times to
come they even have their hands on the
invictus the empire's largest weapon
which went missing 700 years ago and was
deemed lost for good but this is just a
starting point back on trantor brother
day decides the fate of brother dawn who
we found out was unwillingly involved in
a plot to overthrow the empire over the
course of the season brother don fell in
love with one of his servants a gardener
by the name of azura he confided in her
that he's not like his brothers he's
colorblind and left-handed but how could
this be he's supposed to be an exact
copy this doubt led him to escape
fearing if his brothers found out about
his differences they would kill him so
he seeks refuge with azura only to be
betrayed by her she's part of a
resistance the one responsible for
genetically modifying his dna meaning
someone on the inside must have had
access to the genetic tanks in which
their bodies are made this is a plan
that was years in the making and the
only person i can think of who would
have access is their servant demerizal
this is interesting for a number of
reasons first demarzel is supposed to be
programmed never to bring harm to a
member of the genetic dynasty but on the
other hand she does have motive to bring
harm she is the last of her kind her
fellow robots were killed by the very
dynasty she has sworn to protect she is
also a devout believer in luminism a
religion which almost elected a woman by
the name of zephyr halima who is an
enemy to the empire in episodes 6-8 we
see how brother day tries to sway the
vote away from halama to someone more in
line with the emperor that's because
halima believes in something called the
primary octavo a heretic scripture that
links the soul to individual sentience
in other words because the emperor is a
copy he does not possess a soul
therefore he is incapable of change this
would put the emperor in direct conflict
with the very tenets of luminism tenants
that believe change is natural and
therefore a holy progression and
luminism has 3 trillion followers so he
can't afford to start a war with them so
to get over this hurdle brother day
embarks on the spiral a 170 kilometer
holy trek through scorching desert which
few survive it is said that those who
make it to the end are granted a vision
now here is where brother day like his
ancestors rewrites history he does make
it to the end but lies about his vision
stating that he saw a birth root a
birthrate is deeply linked to the
creation of the lumenism religion and
his vision is interpreted by the ring of
zephyrs as being a holy indication that
his soul is not one of stagnation of
course we learn later that this was all
a lie brother day received no such
vision when he reached the end of the
spiral as dimmer zell says of those who
don't receive a vision
seeing nothing
i would not wish that emptiness on
anyone thousands of years ago demerizel
completed the spiral and she herself
received a vision but we never find out
what that vision is if she is in fact
working against the empire it could have
something to do with that after all when
she suddenly kills brother dawn who was
going to be spared by brother day for
his involvement in the overthrow she
rips off her face in anguish perhaps
something she had spent several years
planning was coming undone as we learned
later in the episode the shadowmaster
informs brother day that not only
brother dawn's dna has been changed but
also his own the rebels have tainted all
the copies however brother dusk is
currently being tested so he might be
the last pure copy and it makes sense
that brother day's dna has been changed
any previous clone would have opted to
kill brother dawn but brother day was
going to spare him as dimmer zell says
about all the clones in episode 2 how
often do we choose this
you always do brother day choosing the
non-violent option indicates something
has changed with things settling down on
terminus salver hardin begins her search
for answers she's been experiencing
these visions both of a young boy and
girl but isn't sure where they're coming
from we learned that salvor was the
result of her mother being in vitro
fertilized with gail dornick's egg and
rache selden's sperm eggs and sperm
would have been stored as part of the
colony's seed program although the show
doesn't really go into much depth as to
salvor's mother's motivation here those
visions of a young boy and girl were of
her mother and father gail and reish
this revelation causes salvor to take
off in the middle of the night with her
lover hugo ship the beggar they have a
tearful goodbye and she tells them she
has a lead on where to go this ends up
being her biological mother's planet of
synax speaking of her mother gail
dornick has gone on her own crazy
journey this season she won a math
competition by solving the abraxas
conjecture a problem which hadn't been
solved in 500 years this put her in
touch with harry selden who she later be
accused of being complicit in his murder
forcing her to escape the colony ship
this would lead her to a secret ship
which was meant for race and the
discovery of harry selden's
consciousness embedded in the very
weapon that was used to kill him it's
here we learn there is a second
foundation on harry's homeworld of
helicon we never get to see what happens
on helicon as gail forces her way off
the ship tired of being lied and
manipulated to by harry she ends up
putting herself back in cryo and
traveling back to cynics a journey that
takes her 138 years there she finds her
homeworld has succumbed to rising sea
levels something that was hinted at
earlier on in the season and as she
finds her home underwater she notices a
blinking light a light which will lead
her to a pot containing her daughter
salver hardin we aren't exactly sure how
she got here or for how long but with
the foundation being renewed for season
2 we'll be sure to find out this leaves
us with three major storylines to jump
off from brother daenerysel the citizens
of foundation and gail and salvor i
thought it was quite curious when they
showed gail still had racist dagger a
dagger that contained harry selden's
consciousness so i wouldn't be surprised
if harry and gail will be reunited once
again whether it be on synax or
elsewhere but i want to hear what you
thought of this first season of
foundation was it enough to keep you
intrigued and what do you think will
happen in season 2. thanks for watching
be sure to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at think story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you